where are you from  right here back to serve your community  thank you for choosing me i require  discipline  stick to your rank never question an  order yes matron  i won't keep you if you don't fit  we have to move nearly all the patients  out because of the cut tonight  you will stay on the dark shift does the  dog bother you  a place people dying should never be  allowed to get that  dark  i love working nights you can get up to  all sorts  a bit dark won't know yet what is that  smell it's like it's burning  [Music]  who did that  something chased me into the basement  when i looked there was nowhere  are you just making this up no i'm not  making up  a nurse must give of herself entirely  sacrifice  how much are you willing to give  i wish  besides  me  [Music]  hello  you